la carrière de prenois pelleteuse et
chargeurs sont de retour sur le chantier
depuis mi avril
désormais cette entreprise de travaux
publics tentent de se relancer mais le
volume d'activité depuis le début de
l'année s'est réduit de moitié par
rapport à 2019 conséquence le patron a
dû se séparer de ses intérimaires des
intérimaires l'entreprise prennent qu'un
en général c'est 5 % de notre effectif
nous avons 80 salariés
ça fait quatre personnes aujourd'hui
nous sommes à 0 personnes en intérim du
fait d'avoir été arrêté nous avons pas
repris l'activité normale encore à ce
jour
les appels d'offres sont peu nombreux
donc nous l'avons pas repris
d'intérimaires l'intérim
le secteur s'est effondré pendant la
crise sanitaire en bourgogne franche
comté
l'activité a plongé jusqu'à -50 9% en
avril de mars à mai 23 1750 postes ont
été supprimés dans cette agence
d'intérim
oui ces deux nouveaux rachats de ses
partenaires on a assisté à l'hécatombe
l'activité a baissé de 40 % en avril les
secteurs les plus impactés
comme on le sait les premiers commerces
restauration qui aujourd'hui ont fermé
les btp qui n'ont pas pu ouvrir leurs
chantiers comme à l'habitude depuis la
crise de 2008 on n'avait jamais connu ça
la crise sanitaire
une épreuve supplémentaire pour les
étudiants à la recherche d'emplois
saisonniers pendant le confinement
anaïs la rue et a envoyé une trentaine
de candidatures sans succès pour
l'instant
à vous de la situation sanitaire c'est
difficile tout d'abord parce que ça a
retardé
de l'e recrutement etc mi avril
donc je suis à la boulangerie près de
chez moi et je leur ai demandé donc si
recrutait pendant les grandes vacances
et elle m'a dit je cite on ne sait pas
revenez plus tard voilà donc j'y suis
retourné après confinement et c'était
exactement la même chose qu'on sait pas
ramener plus tard la crise n'a pas
impacté tous les secteurs aussi
violemment la grande distribution fait
figure d'exception dans ce supermarché
20 saisonniers l'an dernier ils seront
autant cet été